the streets of bath should be buzzing
with life
this historic town usually draws
tourists
from all over the world
but lockdown has shuttered its
attractions
a drastic move designed to stop even
more
pandemic deaths my dad
when he was alive my my world was
complete
this is the father and grandfather they
grieve
nya's ali is one of the 100
000 lives lost to the pandemic here
in the uk his family have missed him
every single day since last april
i never knew he had covered i just
thought it's a it's an
infection that he's got and he'll be
he'll be better and he'll come home my
grandad was very frightened he was
crying he the last things he said that
please
don't leave me the alleys are one of the
families
grieving for a loved one taken from them
in the past year
there are 100 000 more just like them
it's almost impossible for any one of us
to
truly comprehend the scale of this
tragedy
imagine a city the size of bath now try
to imagine
every single life in that city lost
to a single virus and each one of these
one hundred thousand lives
is a person a father a mother a
grandparent
a son a daughter being mourned
by their families
a frontline healthcare worker like dr
ahmed
would have tended to each and every one
of those 100
000 people i don't think i could have
ever been as prepared
for the number of deaths that we've seen
during this pandemic
he like his medical colleagues has
witnessed
untold suffering in all my kind of 14
years of experience as a doctor and my
training beforehand i never thought we
would come across such a pandemic we
deal with a lot of cases in care homes
and often these individuals may not have
any next of kin or may just be very
isolated
anyway but it's really sad to see these
individuals who
may have been towards the end at the end
of their lives but may not have been and
unfortunately
a lot of them have passed away because
of coronavirus this milestone
unthinkable a year ago is not even the
true
cost of this tragedy this is the
chemotherapy questions
that um you all asked me kelly russell's
is another life taken last year but a
young mother did not die of covert 19
she had stage 4 bowel cancer the number
of people who are going to be dying from
cancer
is is now accelerating this is costing
people's lives
her devastated father craig told me
kelly might still be alive today
if her cancer treatment had not been
stopped
a basic mindset at that time was that
to her the chemotherapy was keeping her
alive
when you're 31 years old and you've got
a six-year-old son
every day is precious one hundred
thousand
lives gone that's more than the
population
of this city all lost
in just 12 months and these
are the lives taken directly by covert
the real tragedy is much
much greater ashish joshi sky news
bath